tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
momento sono fa vj e sono tutto in tema
natalizio e sono contentissimo di fare
questo video perché a distanza di un
botto di tempo voglio ritornare su una
delle cose che nel tempo mi ha reso
orgoglioso di essere uno youtube harry
sto parlando ragazzi degli immagina per
chi non lo sapesse sono dei racconti
erotici aspetta che non fini che fanno
le mie fan su di me il problema ragazzi
che questa cosa è sfuggita un po di mano
ok e adesso vi farò vedere il perchè
dovete immaginarvi questa storia di io
come protagonista secondario è il
protagonista principale di questa storia
e la fan che ha scritto la storia ho
dovuto fare una dieta per tenere il
fegato a posto perché adesso stiamo per
demolirlo tutto in una botta perché
s'era già messo di merda morivo un
giorno vai dall'estetista per farti fare
la ceretta le gambe e di sexy fino
adesso non c'è un cazzo c'entra in
edifici aspetti che sia il tuo turno poi
una voce maschile ti chiama entra in una
stanza e ti sdrai sul lettino subito
dopo arriva un ragazzo moro sulla
ventina hicks piacere io sono lorenzo ti
dice con un sorriso to piacere prepara
tutta la roba per la ceretta per poi
applicarti una striscia sulla gamba
della strappa con violenza e tu quasi
urli questo non è il sexy ci sono tutti
i peli su quel cazzo di cose merda il
ragazzo si accorge che quasi urli dal
dolore così ti si avvicina mettendosi
sopra di te l vedi ora come ti faccio
urlare io piccola e tutto questo con la
striscia di cerette di peli in mano sono
proprio tutto eccitato gambe amore e
peli sei stata assunta come supplenti in
una scuola media vicina a casa tua
durante l'intervallo stai spesso da sola
finché un giorno ti si avvicina un tuo
collega la ragazza che avrà scritto sta
roba andrà le medie quindi come fai a
essere assunta come supplente alle medie
se a malapena ci vai a buongiorno si
buongiorni simo signorina buongiorni se
non avevo mai vista in questa scuola che
ci fa come sono da supplente della
professoressa di matematica a capisco
comunque piacere io sono lorenzo
iniziato a conversare tutti gli
intervalli li passate insieme
il che non ti dispiace un giorno lorenzo
ti dice che devi mostrarti una cosa e tu
lo seguì ti porta in quello che sembra
uno sgabuzzino e chiude la porta a
chiave
tu e arrivo questi punti ed è sempre
difficile continuare a leggere
lorenzo visci città piccola dice
iniziando a sbottonarsi la camicia
polizia ma ci sentiranno basta che non
urli troppo
e subito dopo compare un ghigno sul suo
volto ricca uno stupratore che cazzo se
in discoteca a questa già grafica
avanzata ad immagina se in discoteca ti
sei vestita molto sexy ma ti sei
ubriacata un po troppo insieme a te al
tuo amico che si chiama lorenzo e belle
belle vieni un attimo in bagno con me io
certo arrivé lorenzo ti prende ti
comincia a baciare dappertutto senza
smettere di ti leva ma questo in
discoteca vabbè comincia a baciare
dappertutto senza smettere ti leva il
vestito e l'intimo e quando rimane
tenuti tutti e due
venite anche chi ha scritto questa
storia cappuccino perché sedurla quando
puoi sedarla ma non è neanche questo
perché ci siamo se dati tutti e due
perché siamo svenuti a caso ma che cosa
che non farò la mattina dopo tt tutti
trovi in un bagno sporchissime ti trovi
in un bagno sporchissime e lorenzo nude
cerchie di svegliarle vabbè io mi
sveglio e dico ed anche se eravamo
ubriachi mi sei veramente piaciuta o
vabbè vabbè discoteca chiusano eravamo
nudi nel bagno abbiamo continuato a
essere nudi nel bagno svenuti non è
entrato nessuno in tutta la serata ci
sono svegliati la mattina con una
discoteca chiusa nudi nel bagno senza
privi di sensi non guarda 50 sfumature
di grigio può accompagnare solo 6 alla
festa è questa c'è la stessa grafica di
qua di prima e quindi un po micro
addosso 6 alla festa del tuo amico
lorenzo che disse che te ne sei
innamorata perdutamente all'italiano
ovunque ci giochi e parecchio ceci fave
a cazzotti forte lorenzo chi si avvicina
ai piccola il mio regalo
io cazzo lori l'ho dimenticato a casa
sulla faccia di lory
egli si forma un sorriso a era la stessa
frase un aspetto rileggo con la
punteggiatura che avrebbe dovuto metter
cazzo lori l'ho dimenticato a casa
puntoacapo maiuscola sulla faccia di
lory risi forno un sorrisetto pervertito
lorenzo ti prende per un braccio e ti
porta in bagno io lori ma che l penso
che questo regalo mi piacerà
gli ho regalato un cane un cane l'ho
regalato un cane perché le davano in
omaggio anche un dizionario di italiano
che le serve un sacco vedo immagina se
gli al cinema nel bel mezzo del film
senti qualcuno che ti dica la spalla e
ancora prima che tutti i giri lui ti
bacia più istintivamente alzi la mano
per tirargli uno schiaffo ma quando
capisci che è l'ora e cuore trasformi la
schiappa ma perché non sapete scrivere
trasformi la schiaffa in una carezza va
bene facciamone una un po più easy
perché se non sono tutte troppo spinte
non va bene stai male e lei la febbre
alta e il giorno eletto anniversario con
lorenzo ma non lo potete festeggiare
perché stai male mentre sei distesa a
letto senti qualcuno cantare da sotto il
tuo balcone allora ti affacci vedi
lorenzo con in mano una rosa rossa è una
chitarra che ti canta una canzone io che
canta una canzone va beh lorenzo urla ti
amo
immagina rosso perché ci sono mancati in
questo periodo 6 è il parco da sola e ti
stai mangiando un gelato su una panchina
ad un certo punto vedi un ragazzo alto
magro avete pensato tutti i sexy io lo
so perché vi conosco tutti quanti vi
conosco i capelli color nocciola e gli
occhi color nutella che è la stessa cosa
però va beh lui ti si avvicina e ti dice
è piccola sono lorenzo mi conosci non
credi che sia meglio leccare qualcosa
certo certo ovvio io vado da una seduta
su una panchina a caso già oggi a mi
chiamo lorenzo 2 leccare qualcos'altro e
via di polizia nastro sei sposata con
lorenzo ostuni fa vj grazie ha
specificato tra cinque anni ed avete una
bambina di tre anni a madonna si è
trattato la per la colazione
dopo che hai passato una notte attiva
con lorenzo
vabbè figlia papa ma perché stanotte ho
sentito la mamma genere il tuo nome
vuoi un fratellino sì o no a natale poi
fare quello che non puoi fare male
macchiava 3 3 ore e mezzo che la figlia
e traumatizzato per il resto della vita
prendo giallo che miri piglio nac ero a
casa da sola quando sento il rumore e
venire dalla cucina allora vado a
controllare senza trovare l'origine del
suono già che mi trovavo lì aprì la
dispensa e per cercare da mangiare
ecco che saltò fuori dalla dispensa
lorenzo ma che cazzo è stati spence cioè
io mi nascondo nelle dispense di cibo a
cercare i vasetti di nutella degli altri
mi guardò con aria intensa e mi sbatte
al muro e fissandomi negli occhi disse
dimmi dove hai messo la nota è come lo
sapevo dimmi dove hai messo la nutella o
ti farò vedere di che cosa sono capace
leccando mi la faccia ce n'è una normale
una normale perché devo leggere queste
cose quante saranno sei a casa tua e
stai leggendo un libro quando lorenzo il
tuo fidanzato ti abbraccio la dieta e ti
bacia questi sistema avvicinate ti
prende in braccio sempre continuando a
baciarti il moro il moro il moro si
toglie la maglia e mentre di sta per
sbottonare i jeans loafer minore i
sussurri con voce roca l si piccola ho
le mie cose
dc per borini e tanti a leggere
lasciando una faccia mista tra lo
stupore alla tristezza se la faccia del
tuo fidanzato tratto da una storia vera
ma proseguiamo di questa non leggerò
assolutamente un cazzo perché ho letto
solo questa frase mi basta nori voglio
che tu ti prende la mia verginità come
hai fatto con il mio cuore pablo neruda
chi chi è piacere io sono io lo so vengo
da lo so io
fidati lo so ma che oggi si è andata a
casa del tuo migliore amico lorenzo ed
avete scopato tutto il giorno
ora è tutto pulito a cosa pensavi
pervertita essi sono come una pervertita
maledetta tv è il tuo amico lorenzo vi
rivedete dopo tanto tempo a un certo
punto to attorcigli le mani attorno ai
suoi fianchi a ferri il suo portafogli e
scappi brava questo voleva porca eva
oggi tu e il tuo fidanzato lorenzo fate
un anno insieme viti nevica into you di
ariana grande che grazie a dio non
conosco perché il titolo
la sera va lui viene a casa tua e vico
corato un po sul letto perché mi ha
dedicato proprio into you e noi inizia
baciarti con foga e passione vi
spogliate lorenzo ti amo sarà la nostra
prima volta infatti quello che avevo
ricevuto la nostra prima volta amore mio
con questa espressione con proprio
questa espressione immagina di essere il
gatto di lorenzo è che lui ti coccoli
ogni giorno dormite nello stesso letto
giocate lui ti pulisce i tuoi bisogni
che problemi hai tesoro che problemi
fatti spiegare dalla mamma che esistono
gli psicanalisti va bene ragazzi basta è
stato e quanto tragico però lasciamo
perdere però che video vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi e mi è piaciuto tanto c'è
proprio mi ha dato una botta di vita
quindi ragazzi miei spero che vi sia
piaciuto como sente chiuso l'argomento è
un mi piace anche la pace di facebook e
come gli yacht è il meno script
consiliari ti chiedevi ci picchiavano
possiamo video e da ragazzi